في مقطع فيديو منتشر ومتداول بشكل كبير
على المنصات وعامل حال من الضجه والغضب
الواسع في مصر خلونا نشوفه مع بعض
[موسيقى]
منه اكثر من هذه الثواني القديمه
وانه الفيديو هذا عباره عن رهان بينهم
لمين بيقدر يركب ابره كان ولا لرضيع وهو
معصوب العينين
يعني بصراحه استهتار ولام وبلاو شيء غير
اخلاقي و كارثه بكل المقاييس هاي كانت
تعليقات بصراحه المصريين وغير المصريين
على هذا المقطع ولكن الغضب والاستنكار او
بعد الغضب والاستنكار تحركت الجهات
الرسميه نقابه التمريض في المحافظات كشفت
مفاجاه بتخلي القصه لسه صادمه اكثر
يوم الخميس
على الماسنجر حد بيسالني سؤال بيقول لي
ايه رايك لو ممرض او شخص بيركب كانه وهو
مغمض عينه
وداخل في تحدي مع احد ثاني بمناسبه
الفيديو اللي حضرتك بتتكلم عليه بيقول
لحضرتك ده مش همم ممرض ولا ليه اي علاقه
بالتمريض ولا نقابه التمريض وغير مقيد
بجداره النقابه وغير مقيد بسريلات النقابه
وغير مرخص لان المفروض ان الممرض همم لما
بيتخرج من خلال الاماكن الحكوميه وبيجيء
عندي هنا في النقاب
تخيلوه انه طلع حتى مش ممرض عموما يعني
وزاره الداخليه كشفت المزيد من التفاصيل
ببيان نزلتهم امبارح واعلنت في ضبط
الشخصين اللي ظهروا في المقطع اللي بيصور
واللي بيحن الطفل وقالت انه الشاب الي
بركب الكانيلا هو مساعد ممرض في حضانه
تتبع لجمعيه خاصه وانه اللي معه بالفيديو
طالب بمعهد التمريض وبيشتغل في نفس
الحضانه و الاثنين اعترفوا انهم عملوا
الفيديو لقيتهار مهاره الاول في العمل
وتعليم ممرضين اخرين والبيان اكد بيان
الداخليه اكد انه جاري اتخذ الاجراءات
اللازمه بحقهم اما بالنسبه للمركز الصحي
بحسب بيان لمحافظ المنيا فتقرر اغلاق قيام
من سماه البيان احد العاملين فيه من
منتحيلي من هناك التمريض بيعمل يهدد حياته
احد الاطفال واضاف البيان كمان انه اصلا
المعاينه بينت انه المركز في مخالفات
عديده مثل اداره منشاه طبيه بعماره سكنيه
وممارسه افراد مهنه التمريض بدون ترخيص
كمان وجود معمل تحاليل غير مرخص ووجود
حضانات حضانات اكثر من المرخص له سوء ايضا
تخزين ادويه كمان